here's some advice from dreamworks  founder steven spielberg from zugo 101  find your passion  the only time i'm totally happy is when  i'm watching films or making them i  never felt comfortable with myself  because i was never part of the majority  i always felt awkward and shy and on the  outside of the momentum of my friends  lives  i like the smell of film i just like  knowing there's film going through the  camera  i'd love to build a company that will  continue to make movies well beyond me  someday i'd like to help start something  great to discover a new talent and give  them a start  to learn more about finding your passion  check out zuga 101 in the link below